for Jake you know the nape fight is
still there I think Nate would give him
a world of trouble now the Conor fight
moved down the road I think those things
are still there for these guys I don't
think it's gonna hurt his next fight if
he were to fight a Tommy or Nate you
know I think a lot of people are going
to see him lose now that he's lost and
maybe there's a little pressure off him
too all right you lost a decision maybe
you thought you won whatever you'll be
okay man it's the fight game people take
losses you'll be okay now to me we'll
see you know JQ has all the money in the
world makes all the money in the world
off YouTube and his Instagram and his
Network where he has like a sports
network down his own TV show and his
merch kids crushing him now we see how
bad he wants to be a boxer trust me
fighting is the best sport in the world
when you're knocking dudes out you're
undefeated when you lose it's the worst